i mean this is exactly why gain of
function research is what it is it's
like we can't do this yet so we're going
to
let evolution take a shot and see if it
can create kind of the neighborhood of
what we're looking for yeah you use
serial passaging i mean in fact
that crazy paper the uh christian
anderson paper in nature that keeps
being pointed to
from like march or april of last year
yeah it says well this isn't a
designed virus because we would have
thought the spike protein
would fail with this confirmation for me
if i had been doing this research i
would not have created that thing
right which you know it is true i think
that nobody would have designed the
spike protein we got
it is not true that the protocols we use
in the lab wouldn't have put together
that spike protein
i want do you think that's intentionally
confusing do you think
you think he's he was putting that out
into the world in order to be confusing
because he's certainly aware of what
serial passaging and
gain of function research is well i
would just say that the history
of those two papers the lancet paper and
which is
27 multi-author paper just saying yeah
don't worry about it nothing to see here
let's put it this you've got
dasic on one on the lancet paper and
you've got dasic not
named in the second one but there is
an email chain that puts him behind it
and so
uh i do have the sense he was a police
consultant yeah
the paper um you know i hesitate to say
anybody deliberately wrote anything that
they knew was false on the other hand
it's really hard to figure out how
somebody
who is as prominent would have come up
with something so
obviously and transparently wrong well
but i mean
but but it has worked
yes right like the the confusion like it
didn't it hadn't even occurred to me i
think we've said this on this live
stream before
it hadn't even occurred to me until
maybe after we were on mar even at the
end of january
that some people heard lab lake and
thought
created de novo from scratch by humans
right
like it literally never occurred to me
that someone could hear loudly can think
that and that's partially you know my
ignorance
but it also like that anderson paper
specifically like created that narrative
it created it and i don't know if it
existed before
well so at least the following
at least the fact that people
not knowing what this these sorts of
techniques
are would hear oh did this leak from a
laboratory and might think you know
diabolical geniuses writing viruses in
private for you know weapons purposes or
whatever
it was incumbent on those who are well
placed in this to say actually
that's not what's being discussed this
what we are discussing is something like
the hybridizing of viruses that we get
from nature
or the use of serial passaging to
enhance viruses that we get from nature
or a combination thereof
or the splicing of a gene individually
from some place that we want
however we don't believe that that
happened because and then make your damn
argument
but that they didn't do that they took
the advantage of people's
um fanciful imaginations as to what was
being alleged in order to hide and say
none of that could possibly have
happened and you'd have to be a fool to
think it could
right right and so yes
it is uh it is extremely misleading
yeah at best
[Music]
you